a search for mines is conducted by men
of the 100 first airborne division on a
small dirt road outside of tweet wall
here on the central coastal plain of
Vietnam 376 kilometers northeast of
Saigon American troops are securing a
supply route leading from the coast to a
new heliport being constructed 10
kilometers beyond wewa as the mine
sweeping detail moves ahead security
patrols scour the area for word making
sure there are no VC a battalion
intelligence officer arrives by chopper
to interrogate a captured VC suspect
found lurking in the brush this suspect
was taken into custody by the security
patrols now with the aid of an
interpreter the man is questioned he
will later be taken to headquarters for
further interrogation meanwhile
artillery units of the 1st air cavalry
division located in the area begin
firing a support mission the sky
troopers are beginning a new search and
destroy mission deep within the Vietcong
controlled wilderness country of who yen
province some of the worst lowland
jungle is located in this sector
to support these operations against the
enemy in Fujian province a new heliport
is being constructed by engineers of the
100 first airborne division here on 7
july basic construction of strips and
pads is being completed tank trucks
spread penna prime a surface conditioner
to keep the dust down then a final
grading is given the runway a tractor
and grading sled are used for this job
the pads where the helicopters will be
part are surfaced with steel matting
when set in place each matt is linked
one to the other creating a continuous
covering for the entire parking area
when sunday comes to this raw wilderness
area chaplains fly in to conduct
religious services there are no
buildings yet erected and the altar
stands beneath the open sky but as
always the sermon is a message of
inspiration and comfort in this brief
interval the war against the Viet Cong
seems far away sunday in Vietnam
the aviation support elements of the US
Army in Vietnam are today engaged in a
wide variety of duties the aerial
delivery of all types of ammunition to
forward areas is one of those missions
here as elsewhere in the service the
transfer of supplies from the source to
the delivery crews requires paperwork
another assigned duty is the air lifting
of paratroops of the Vietnamese military
force in this instance caribou aircraft
are used to transport arvin soldiers on
an airborne strike in the Delta region
of the 4th Corps area over the drop zone
the Arvin troopers jump with drill like
precision in the Vietnamese conflict as
nowhere else the employment of air
support in the field of logistics has
reached an all-time peak of efficiency
throughout South Vietnam army aircraft
are providing day and night support to
ground forces engaged in hunting down
and destroying the Viet Cong
the air traffic control company whose
mission it is to support all army air
activities in Vietnam has its company
headquarters at Thompson with Air Force
Base Saigon here command functions are
exercised over four platoons each
assigned to one of the four Army Corps
area 1 platoon supports company
headquarters and provides air traffic
control for army aircraft in the core
area which includes Saigon the platoon
also is responsible for its
communications in the core area
involving telephone teletypewriter and
radio communications here personnel
troubleshoot a newly installed telephone
terminal box a repairman checks radio
equipment in use in the flight control
center and flight operations center vans
which have just been set up in a new
location at Thomson or a Craig mast
antenna is erected to handle traffic
from the flight operations center van
once installed on its base the Craig
mast antenna is elevated to its
operating position as platoon personnel
man the guyline then radio
teletypewriter circuits are placed in
operation to tie the installation to
company headquarters
another US army unit in the Dominican
Republic prepares for departures tank
company sees a part of the American
Brigade inter-american police force tax
its equipment for the trip back to home
base at Fort Stewart Georgia company
seve arrived in the Dominican Republic
in the fall of nineteen sixty-five and
helped in training programs related to
infantry operations during the October
riot C Company tanks leave camp in Santo
Domingo and head for the marshaling area
at the beach for loading onto LST in
March of nineteen sixty six elements of
this unit spent five weeks in Puerto
Rico conducting gunnery exercises the
company also carried out demonstrations
of its capabilities for Dominican
military officials and members of the
inter-american police force at Red Beach
message of cheer for the departing unit
as the LSTs come in to load up
in addition to tanks and personnel
carriers see company has its own support
trucks trailers jeeps and a tracked
vehicle recovery unit moving company
equipment aboard the LSTs is a two-day
operation
farewell ceremonies include a send off
by an Army Band on hand for the
departure is Brigadier General Robert
Linville commanding general of US forces
in the Dominican Republic the main body
of troops goes by air and the general
participates in another departure
ceremony at San Isidro Airport awards
are given by general Linville for
outstanding service in the Dominican
crisis a delegation of inter-american
police force representatives takes part
in the farewell between their regular
assignments the men of Company C found
time to engage in civic action projects
in Santo Domingo the unit supported a
school for needy girls and was
instrumental in obtaining donations for
the project from us civic organizations
and religious groups now for the men of
the armor company it's adios amigos as
the big c-130 transports take off for
stateside
in Heidelberg Germany at headquarters of
the United States Army Europe on 20 July
a ceremony is held to honor the
commander of the northern army group
General Sir John W Hackett he's
accompanied by General Andrew P O'Meara
the commander-in-chief of the US Army
Europe a VIP audience looks on as
general Hackett receives a 17 gun salute
the honor guard is from the 529 MP
company the guard marches to the music
of the headquarters ban general Hackett
expresses his desire to meet some of the
spectators on the visitors gallery these
include members of the General Staff of
headquarters US Army Europe as well as
their ladies general Hackett is joined
when he leaves by lady Hackett and
daughter Mary the general is now bound
for briefings here at Heidelberg and
then of the central Army Group
headquarters at second I'm
you
you
Oh
championships at wiesbaden freudenberg
Germany scheduled from the 14th to the
23rd of July more than 1,000
participants try for awards in rifle
pistol and trap shooting in the largest
such contests ever to be held United
States contestants are winning more than
their share of metals in this 39th
annual contest army captain Donald Adams
and Lieutenant Gary Anderson place first
and second in small bore prone and
standing positions and with Captain John
Foster and William trilling win gold
medals as a team as the matches continue
lieutenant Margaret Thompson wins the
women's individual small-bore
championship on another range the
matches for the center fire pistol are
being held sergeant first class William
Blankenship places first with his
individual pistol score and joined by
Air Force captain Franklin green
Sergeant John Ditmore and Army Staff
Sergeant aim / Gator captured the team
trophy airman first class Kenneth Jones
has top individual score in the clay
pigeon event Jones lieutenant Gordon
Horner Charles Jensen and captain
Franklin green makeup the winning team
John King getter of Fort Benning his
third in the running for event then he
army sergeant Edmund Muller and Air
Force sergeants Richard Brown and
Frederick Dean placed second as a team
US Army Berlin plays host to the 6th
german-american volksfest the open-air
Carnival which annually helps promote
good community relations
today's welcoming remarks are made by
Major General John Franklin Jr the US
commander in Berlin general Franklin and
haunts Gunther hot Berlin Senator for
finance cut the ribbon officially
opening the fair this year's volksfest
tracing the history of Texas's
independence from Mexico draws a record
crowd for West Berliners who live inside
the borders of the Iron Curtain
recreation of the Alamo and the heroic
stand of its defenders has a special
meaning various exhibits suggest the
early days of the fortress in the 18th
century when it was a center of Spanish
culture and an important part of Spain's
plans for a Great Western Empire members
of the mosaics a group of handicapped
Berliners demonstrate the arts and
crafts talked to the Indians at the
alamo by the spanish padres in the 1700s
a message to the volksfest from Texas
Governor Connally recalls the sacrifice
of two native Germans in the siege of
the Alamo the Berlin old Texas cowboy
club holds guard mount at the replica of
the fortress though the demonstrations
are in keeping with carnival gaiety four
letters become familiar with some of the
costumes and customs of the early
American West
u.s. soldiers in Berlin foster a spirit
of understanding with the people in the
area the volksfest contributes to this
understanding with its enactment of a
traumatic incident in the American
heritage